so the push to cut red tape on finding a
vaccine and four treatments in the
meantime like the plasma that Leland
talked about that's why we want to start
tonight with our first guest senator and
dr. John Barrasso of Wyoming senator
welcome back to Fox News and I could to
have you thanks okay so let's talk a
little bit about vaccine this is what
doctor foul she said today when he was
asked about this timeframe but he's been
talking about 12 to 18 months here's
what he said I mean the vaccine is as I
said it's on target we're still in phase
one a few months from now we'll be in
Phase two and I think we're right on
target for the year to a year and a half
okay there are some skeptics out there
though dr. maria elena batad see who is
the co-director of the Texas Children's
Hospital Center for vaccine development
talking about this time frame says the
reality is that's probably not going to
happen we may have real optimism and
some safety evidence by then but not a
vaccine doctor senator what say you
because it seems like doctor foul she's
been pretty guarded about things that
he's put out there but he sounds rather
confident about this with regard to the
vaccine well I'd stick with dr. Fauci
I've known him for many years he is a
world expert in this for a vaccine to
work you need to be it needs number one
to be safe because you're talking about
giving it to 300 million Americans and
it has to be effective so you're going
to give it to a lot of people it has to
make sure no one of those folks are
harmed by it and then if they're exposed
to the virus it needs to work for them
to be able to fend it off I'm very
excited about the research that's being
done we have a number of different
private companies researchers who are
really making a difference and sure this
isn't something that's going to be
developed overnight
but if we can have this done in the kind
of time that dr. fowey talks about that
will be a world record okay so I want to
play something else from dr. Burks from
today she talked about these antibody
tests that if we can ramp up the tests
that would allow people to see if
they've had Co vyd 19 recovered from it
and that they would be able to then move
about safely and she was saying
primarily for healthcare workers this
would be a huge boon and she's put out a
challenge here's what she said I think
really being able to tell them the peace
of mind that would come from knowing you
already were
affected you have antibody you're safe
from reinfection 99.9 percent of the
time and so this I think would be very
reassuring to our frontline health care
workers and our universities can do that
by Friday I mean senator by Friday that
sounds amazing she used a little
terminology I didn't understand but she
talked about how this had been done and
scaled up before with HIV and SARS and
some other things but to have something
available this soon I mean what kind of
role could our universities play in
getting something like this out there so
that our health care workers can know if
they're safe if they have the antibodies
and moving forward this would be the
real game-changer and not just for our
health care workers but for all of our
workers in America you know we talk
about people that may have had the virus
but are silent carriers but they have
developed in their body the ability to
fight this off to hold it at bay and by
doing a simple blood test we could find
that they have who these people are that
have built up these antibodies they
could go out and work in the communities
work in the hospitals get back to life
as normal and we would have a much
better understanding of how vulnerable
we were as a society and who was safe to
help make a big difference in our
recovery
I mean how quickly could something like
that be scaled up she talked about
Friday I've heard about these tests that
they're relatively cheap once you can
figure out the antibody and get it going
they said something and she said that
could be more broadly available for
people who do want to return to work in
other sectors in health care whether
it's restaurants or banks or small
businesses or whatever else may be out
there well I think it would really help
in opening up the economy dramatically
for our country if we knew that there
were enough people that met this
criteria so the question is where can
you get the tests how many of the tests
are available can this be done at a
regular point of contact or do you have
to send it in and wait several days like
we do right now for the coronavirus test
this would make a real difference this
is be a blood test that tests it's
called serology test to see if your body
has built up antibodies to fight off
coronavirus it's one of the tests that
they were doing in South Korea
previously and it would make it would
make the big difference in terms of when
America opens up and gets back to
business and we get back to life as we
know it okay let me ask you also about
Leland was talking about the plasma use
and I've seen a number of universities
and healthcare
groups and Hospital groups now putting
out the call if you're somebody who had
coronavirus you've gotten cleared you
have recovered could you come in and do
the plasma they're saying listen they
don't know that it's a guarantee but it
sounds like something that's worked in
the past could be very helpful in this
situation for people who are currently
suffering well I think there is a lot of
optimism for that we saw that work in in
the case of Ebola in Africa people that
had had that and a bill had gotten over
and recovered those were the people that
then were helping treat people as well
as being used as part of the treatment
for the people with Ebola it made a big
difference and if it works also for
coronavirus I think that would also be
significant for all of us yeah be an
answer to prayer all right senator and
dr. Barrasso thank you for making time
for us good to see you great to be with
you